يقول رئيس البلدية دي بلاسيو أن المدينة
لم تتخذ قرارًا بعد بشأن أه إذا
كانت ستلغي حدث تايمز سكوير ليحضر
أه الحشود الآن
يجب أن يتم تطعيمك أظهر دليلًا على
التطعيم إذا احتجزوه ولكن
للأشخاص الذين  تفكر في الذهاب إلى هناك
أو إلى انخفاض الخوخ في أتلانتا أو
أي من هذه الأحداث المماثلة في جميع أنحاء
البلاد ، فماذا ستفعل نصيحتك لهم ،
أو إذا تم تطعيمك ،
فأنت بخير ، ما رأيك
جيدًا ، لا أعتقد ذلك  يجب أن يقوم رئيس البلدية دي
بلاسيو بإلغاء حدث مدينة نيويورك
لأنه يتطلب إثباتًا
للتطعيم وأنه في الهواء الطلق يجب
أن نحافظ على الأحداث التي تكون
آمنة واه وأيضًا
الأحداث الممتعة للناس أيضًا لا يمكننا
إلغاء  كل شيء خاصة إذا كنا
سنعيش مع الطمع في
المستقبل المنظور ، أود أن أقول إنه إذا
اخترت الذهاب تأكد من
تلقيحك وتعزيزك ، فتأكد من
أنك ترتدي
قناعًا على الرغم من أنه في الهواء الطلق إذا كان
هناك  لا يرتدي الكثير من الناس حولك
وهم يرتدون قناعًا جراحيًا ثلاثي الطبقات ، ولا
يرتدون قناعًا من القماش.
قناع جراحي وإذا
كنت ستزور أقارب مسنين
أو الأشخاص الذين يعانون من نقص المناعة بعد الانتظار لمدة
ثلاثة أيام ، قم بإجراء الاختبار ثم شاهد هؤلاء
الأشخاص الضعفاء ،
نعم لا تلغي كل شيء ممتع هذا
هو العنوان الرئيسي الذي حصلت عليه منك دكتور
واين ، شكرًا جزيلاً لكونك  معنا